they literally pay companies to hire
women but do you realize the older
Generations haven't died yet so you're
going to need to give it a couple
Generations before we can actually judge
it I mean it's going to be more older
people that do have jobs that's just
such a car back the older generation
wants to make money if you're telling me
you you tell a 55 year old dude you get
money to hire women you don't think he's
gonna hire more women no that that's not
what I mean I mean until the older
generation have died where there is
still inequality because obviously if
you're going past 60 years old all those
women that are that old still have the
same mindset that they had because they
didn't have I mean from where from what
era like how old are you talking like my
like my mom's like the Equal Pay Gap the
Equal Pay Act was it was in 1964. I'm
talking about opportunities from going
to University so it's going to be 1963
was the equal it's been illegal it is
illegal to pay women less than men I've
been